stop very important announcement
probably the most important announcement
i have ever made okay listen up i don't
know why i said ironically this is
actually great
so g fuel energy tubs are now on
discount
instead of 35.99 they're now 29.99
but here comes the real kicker you still
get
30 off with code pewdiepie huge
this is massive for anyone that goes but
it's so expensive in my country
not that discount you're good no excuse
check out the glorious flavor yusuf
slash and original pewdiepie flavor
the best energy drink on the market i
may be biased
but it's the only thing i drink okay how
do you think i got these mussels
that's g fuel straight in pumping
through these veins
i don't know you guys know i love g-fuel
this is a great offer
it's a great time to stock up an old
favorite is also in stock
cherry lemai limeade lim
ee ade lemade the mind
lemade check out le mans as always g
fuel dot
lie slash pewdiepie don't forget to end
the code pewdiepie at checkout 30
off an additional discount amazing
recommend it
drink it try it everyone loves it i've
never met anyone that say they don't
like it and if they do
we kill them so if you want to die no
i'm just kidding
today i'm going to teach my pug how
useless
he actually is isn't that right edgar
it's time for you to look at other pugs
so you know what a real pug real pug you
hear me
it's supposed to be like are you
watching here look at some cute pugs
look at that pug he doesn't take
attitudes
if anyone gave you attitude you would it
literally if we were robbed edgar would
invite the robbery
time for school come on
wake up it's time for school come on man
are you ready for show edgar you barely
have any teeth show him
show them terrible teeth actually i
brush them every day they're great teeth
you're you you thank me for your teeth
you understand
you never thank me for brushing your
teeth ernie every night i come to give
him teeth
clean he runs away he's pretending that
he can't hear me
time to eat go tell charlie oh
it could be your brother right here look
can you watch i'm trying to have a
wholesome moment with you here you're
not paying attention here put on the hip
[Music]
stop scratching your ears there you go
now watch what is this stop
stop stop stop
[Music]
you can't scratch because you have your
headphones
are you comfortable
[Music]
are you done he's done no
oh you're crazy now you were sleepy two
seconds ago watch the video
you're the worst to react to oh he's
into it now
i can't do this okay just watch
look at cute you can't you're scared of
water anytime i ever see some water
you like that she's too young for you
don't look any time edgar sees water
he's terrifying
he's actually watching it look at him
yeah was that cute are you getting angry
see this is a real puggy cute sweet
a little chubby you
nothing
[Music]
hell see that dog actually wearing
headphones
well watch some pewdiepie and when
you're in it compilations
guys i'm edgar i hear you guys have a
lot of problems
it's like who is today i'm here to help
i don't like that guy
it's not poop it's art
this is on my channel oh which channel
was just uploaded to
step one make those eyes pop step two
put the flash to the max step three
you're done all right
since you guys keep asking oh this is
mine around my house
this is it
well i poop a lot look how look how old
you look now again you're an
old man you got white you got white
beard
huh your old uncle
hey it's okay it's okay to be old
he's not that old i think he looks much
older because he's half
it's called like silver it's like a
different like he's not
old old but he looks he definitely
definitely look old dude
delicious yeah you don't like that guy
you get your food you put it in the
microwave
and then you eat it oh he's getting
angry
you sniffer if she farts that means
you're in
get an owner make him famous get
my anaconda dope
that shot is so good you look so good
again he was a lot fatter back then i
think
the videos on this channel and to give
you a little sample
of all the good stuff that's about to
come here's me playing a horror game
that was cut for our music food
challenge
oh it's so disgusting uh
oh i did that for views
hey gary what are you doing uh i was
just
checking your equipment to make sure you
wouldn't get hurt
come on man it's april fools god damn it
i'm gonna say it ed gary
come on please i'm gonna do it please
don't do it
i'll do it oh you're so cute again
i think you're cuter now
so anger this is an important video and
i want you to i want you to watch
i want you to watch stop it i want you
to watch
this is when i got you this is seven
years ago
eight years ago two hours ago
look at you look at you it's you you
look so different
little pug who's that that's your edgar
allen after the poet
so his name is edgar allen pug his
favorite hobby is
because edgar is so crazy
nothing's changed
yes yes um
nothing's changed you're still crazy but
less crazy for sure
when you like sleeping a lot more now
don't you i can't wait
to meet you oh
why is his tongue out so much he never
has it out put that thing back all right
you're gonna get me demonic types
didn't we do yoga together yeah we did i
want to spend time with you
he's looking so intently with sleepy
uh rest in peace select me
[Applause]
fatality good thing i don't have any
balls bring your height through the
front
it's true sorry about that by the way
oh all right i can't make a long video
on this second one's to sleep
i understand i just wanted to reminisce
and edgar to look at
some videos with me but this has clearly
been a massive failure
thank you for watching i'll see you guys
tomorrow bye bye
you thought it was gay but true
relevance
never really died
welcome to the first undead game use any
item in your inventory and make
memes inside tuber simulator add some of
our patented stickers in there
stickers are emotions memes are emotions
express your emotions with me
show them for likes share them for love
get up for free
and who knows maybe i'll review your
memes the greatest honor of all time
full circle baby download it make a meme
we need subtitles on this